I mean he caveated his remarks so that
he wasn't departing from the official
government line which is that Ukraine
makes the calls here when Ukraine's
ready then Ukraine May negotiate but the
fact that he that comment will be taken
out of context and people will say that
Richie sunac believes that there has to
be a negotiation so at what point are we
going to lean on the ukrainians to
negotiate
um and I think that in Kiev I think it
won't be very they won't welcome the
fact that he said it it's also it's just
not true that all Wars ended the
negotiating tables it's a line we've
heard from the beginning right from the
start people should read a book
occasionally the second world war did
not end in negotiations perhaps yeah so
the first world war did not end in a
meaningful negotiation uh the Sri Lankan
war against the tamils did not end in
negotiation
um the the war indo-china after America
left did not end in negotiation
um the the withdrawal of Britain and
America from Afghanistan was subject to
negotiation in Doha and then those
negotiations were ignored and we were
defeated in Afghanistan we just left
because we couldn't stay any longer lots
of Wars do not end in negotiations some
Wars end because one side wins now it is
quite likely many wars end in
negotiation it's quite likely that this
struggle which is intergenerational
we're going for a very long time it may
or may not end in negotiation but it's
possible that a ceasefire will be
negotiated that's fine and that may be
plausible in the next year say a
ceasefire and it will be a pretty
unstable ceasefire if we get it but to
say all wars end in negotiation is just
historically untrue and it's not very
helpful at this stage you know as I say
I don't think they'll they'll welcome
hearing that in Kiev even with all the
caveats he put around it okay well let's
talk about the war and what's happening
at the moment we had that massive
missile strike across the country
yesterday we've had more information
about it
um what have we been told yes I mean
missile strikes all around the country
this is the 15th since the 10th of
October this is when they began 10th of
October so this is the 15th Nationwide
strike in which they cover lots of
targets around the country with you know
up to 100 missiles and drones and we now
got some quite good figures which the
Ukrainian Air Force has produced and
which have been verified
um generally speaking from the outside
as to what missiles we use and these
these were them these were the the kh101
and the kh553 these are Cruise missed I
was 28 of them 20 caliber cruise
missiles six x-22 missiles now that's
quite interesting those top three
categories are all cruise missiles
they're big most of them are anti-ship
missiles so they've got Warheads of half
a ton or a ton designed against aircraft
carriers and they're using these very
big huge missiles against quite small
targets electricity substations and
water treatment plants so they're using
stuff that they they haven't got the
right missiles then the next three
categories the kinsal is the Hypersonic
missile the x-31 and the s-300 those are
very fast anti
um because suppression of enemy air
defense missiles so they're going to
attack the air defenses they're really
quick and then there were some drones
now if we look at the those things the
fact is that the ukrainians might have
might have been able to shoot down the
top three categories in those top three
categories 20 28 and 6 is 34 and the
ukrainians um seem to have got sorry
it's a 54 big one
um the ukrainians seemed to have got
about 38 of them and so they've got
about 38 out of 54. that's not bad
but of the whole number the 81 plus the
the Shahid the eight drones they didn't
do so well and the fact is they got
quite a number of those they could Chase
but some of those the last four
categories well forget the share heads
for a moment the last three categories
Kinsale the X31 the S 300 they'd never
get them they're all supersonic aren't
they uh they can be yes the Kinsale
certainly is that's 10 times the speed
of sound the others are can be
supersonic and because of the air
defense uh the S 300s Rare Defense
they're very quick and so with what
they've got at the moment the Ukraine's
can't shoot them down until they get
Patriot batteries which they are going
to get at some point in the future so
looking at this it tells us quite a lot
the ukrainians are doing all they can
but it's not enough and the the Russians
are pulling out lots of different sorts
of missile this is quite an effective
attack from their point of view so
they're pulling out lots of different
sorts of missile in order to hit Ukraine
that was the most effective hit two day
two nights ago that they've had since
the beginning and it's because they're
actually dipping deep into their stocks
to get it we're going to
thank you very much